did you see uh recently 21 Savage spoke
about like in Atlanta obviously there's
a lot of gangbang or a lot of gun
violence happening did you see what 21
Savage had said he just kind of was
trying to put a message out there to
everybody to like kind of you know try
to I think I saw a post when he was like
we we need to do better so yeah do
better try to keep the peace like do you
think like it would take somebody like
in that position to kind of like do the
same thing in Chicago or it doesn't
matter like
I mean I feel like
like I told you it's like
we I know me personally bro we was in
Wars from Generations ago that my big
homie am I older than them homie that
was in you feel what I'm saying and then
it just it just came down it just kind
of gets passed on so like that's that
[ __ ] will never be over with I don't
care who you is bro like that should
never be over with [ __ ] can't come to
agreement and come to each other and
talk and be like let's watch this [ __ ]
or leave it alone or uh or he gonna be
considered a hoe he gonna be considered
a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] a [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] pride in the way that [ __ ] ain't
gonna never end it feels like pride is
probably the biggest uh thing standing
in the way in a lot of that [ __ ] right
yeah for sure but you know like I told
you deaf too
pride and death yeah [ __ ] got locked
up since the 80 years he told and he's
still out of jail [ __ ] been trying to
kill him like this [ __ ] it's all type of
situations do you think like um for
someone like yourself that has found a
way to get out of
that environment
is like the only right thing to do is to
kind of get out of Chicago and and try
yeah like I told them in Atlanta so you
feel me you think of Someone Like Chief
Keef I Don't Think Chief Keef's been
back for I don't know how long but you
know it feels like he got about the way
oh no slow something like goddamn and
snuck and never told nobody
no but for the most part though I don't
think you've been out there but hell
yeah like it's better to just get away
you know it's better just get the [ __ ]
out the city
you already got like I'm just saying me
I already got Ops hella Ops
and there's money in this [ __ ]
Fame this [ __ ] bring Mo enemies and more
problems and [ __ ] you feel what I'm
saying so that's just add on so it's
best to just get the [ __ ] away get out
your shitty tuck off and run that [ __ ]
up and take care of your people for real
for real this [ __ ] really dried up in
the streets this [ __ ] over with yeah I
think that's smart man